sono tagli e le mani insegna informatica
da 25 anni presso istituto galilei costa
di lecce e grazie alla tema di questo
the licks ho scoperto di essere un con
divisionario sì perché la mia vita di
docente e carta lizzata stata
caratterizzata da tre grandi con di
visioni anzi no 2,1 grandi condivisioni
mi esprimo con un numero decimale perché
due di queste sono già in atto da
diverso tempo mentre la terza è stata
appena concepita e vela annuncerò fra
pochi minuti su questo palco
la mia storia inizia a metà degli anni
ottanta quando dopo la laurea e
parallelamente all'insegnamento deciso
di dare sfogo alla mia natura di
intraprendere non divento cioè un
imprenditore ma piuttosto un
intraprendere a cui piace creare nuove
imprese inventarsele portarli avanti
portarli al successo o al fallimento e
poi abbandonarle lasciarle prenderne una
nuova intraprendere una nuova dall 86 al
99 ho cofondato
quattro diverse aziende due di queste
sono miseramente terminate le altre due
stanno facendo sempre più ricchi i miei
ex soci e arrivano nel 99 nel 99
nasce la mia prima condivisione nel 99
deciso di dare una svolta radicale alla
mia vita smetto l'intraprendenza esterna
alla scuola è deciso di portare tutte le
mie esperienze tutto il know how dentro
la scuola cioè decidono di condividere
con i miei studenti le mie esperienze e
non mi limito semplicemente a raccontare
loro quello che ho fatto e come l'ho
fatto
al contrario inizio insieme a loro a
creare nuove piccole imprese cercando di
tradurre tutte in
imprese reali oggi queste vengono
chiamate start up
ma per fare questo fate molta attenzione
perché sto per fare coming out
per fare questo sono diventato
l'insegnante fuorilegge o abbandonato
completamente assolutamente tutti i
programmi ministeriali e ho deciso da
quel momento a portare avanti argomenti
che interessavano a me decidevo io volte
per volta cosa affrontare con i ragazzi
e gli ho dedicato circa la metà delle
mie ore di lezione a materie inesistenti
inconsistenti parla di innovazione
creatività sperimentazione
dopo poco tempo insieme alla mia
compagna e collega ea sedici studenti di
quinta superiore
decidiamo di dare vita ad ariano aria
nuova nel nostro dialetto locale
significa alla nuova e arrivano è una
vera e propria società cooperativa utile
ed indispensabile a mettere realmente
concretamente legalmente in atto le
piccole startup dei nostri ragazzi
ariano è una cosa piuttosto innovativa
viene notata e diffusa e anche
attraverso un bellissimo progetto di
generatività curato dall'università
cattolica di milano e dall istituto
luigi sturzo una cosa innovativa che
oggi chiamiamo incubatori acceleratore
di start up giovanili
undici anni fa era semplicemente una
visione dall'ordine i ragazzi hanno
creato curato gestito e quasi sempre
fatto fallire oltre 20 start up oltre 20
piccole imprese
oggi di quelle sono soltanto tre ad
essere sopravvissute a vivere a
proliferare ea creare un reddito per i
ragazzi che l'hanno creata e a voler
ricavare una sorta di percentuale di
sopravvivenza ci attestiamo intorno al
13 per cento e pare che sia un'ottima
percentuale
adesso mi piacerebbe condividere con voi
una di queste start up mi piacerebbe che
vede testé conto come sia facile
semplice a volte che sia possibile
trasformare in business alcune piccole
idee che vengono creati inventate
sulla lavagna di un'aula scolastica la
prima che vi presento è il festival
della dieta medita liana questo festival
sono quattro anni che i ragazzi
organizzano occupano la piazza maggiore
della città a lecce riescono a
convogliare oltre 60 piccole aziende
agroalimentari di qualità del territorio
e contemporaneamente riescono a far
venire in quei giorni migliaia di
turisti perché hanno abbinato questo
festival ha una formula turistica
innovativa si chiama 30 20 10 prodotti
parole significa dormi con 30 magi con
20 compri prodotti alimentari con 10 la
seconda si ama shopping face e curato da
quattro ragazzi danno inventare 4
ragazza di 17 anni e loro vendono ai
commercianti del territorio agli
esercenti il servizio di creare una
pagina facebook e gestire una pagina
facebook lo offrono ai commercianti che
non hanno o il tempo per farlo ho le
competenze per farlo antonio monaco
invece ha creato land where indossare il
territorio lui ha avuto un'intuizione un
giorno ed è venuto lo ricordo ancora ero
un po prima degli esami di maturità nel
corridoio professore ho avuto un'idea
allora permettetemi un attimo questo
piccolo sfogo bellissimo sentirselo dire
sono alcuni anni che io mi vengo fermato
nei corridoi con persone ho avuto
un'idea quasi sempre gliela facciamo ma
qualche volta passa questa idea come nel
caso di antonio monaco antonio moro che
ho avuto questa idea di invertire una
frase che circola nel mondo da 37 anni
37 anni fa fu inventata questa frase
vincente isle of new york
hi low new york è stata copiata in tutte
le lingue store ha copiato per tutte le
città e per tutti i territori
antonio monaco è stato il primo a
invertirlo due persone e se fosse il
salento il primo territorio ad amare la
persona e non ad essere amato ha creato
la maglietta salento laos mi ha
investito in questa idea 50 euro 14 per
stampare i due campioni qualche altra
cosa per mettere carburanti macchia si è
fatto il giro della penisola ha proposto
la sua maglietta in e commercianti
commercianti hanno iniziato a ordinarlo
hanno cominciato a dare un acconto con
quella conto lui ha pagato l'acconto
presso la fabbrica per stamparle è
questo un potentato avanti e con questo
investimento minimo iniziale nel giro di
20 giorni è riuscito in parte a
intascare come guadagno oltre 1.500 euro
poi ovviamente la cosa è andata avanti
ha continuato a lavorare altri ragazzi
invece hanno inventato una carta una
banalissima carta sks la card per dare
sconti agli studenti
questi ragazzi sono riusciti poco tempo
a convincere 80 negozi a convenzionarsi
con questa carta hanno venduto le carta
5 euro l'una agli studenti e quindi
hanno avuto una sorta di doppia fonte
d'ingresso da una parte i commercianti
che spettavano 60 70 euro per
convenzionarsi per un anno e dall'altra
la vendita delle card ai ragazzi qui
un'intera classe invece si è
improvvisata agenzia di viaggi ma una
gestione viaggi particolare non è
un'agenzia di viaggi normale è
un'agenzia di viaggi specializzata sulle
gite turistiche scolastica quindi loro
si rivolgevano ai loro coetanei in tutta
italia dicendo ragazzi perché per
agitano venite giu in salento
movimentando questa attività e quando
arrivava il pullman in città non erano
non c'ero degli adulti ad accogliere
questi ragazzi facciano loro coetani che
li accoglie voli portavano in albergo e
digestivo durante il periodo della gita
master prof è nata da pochi mesi è
l'iniziativa di una classe che ha voluto
cercare in tutta italia tutti quei
docenti extra ordinari li chiamano fuori
dall'ordinario
che fanno delle cose un po diverse ecco
qui una piccola nota è nata dicendo
professore ma lei pensa di essere
l'unico che fa queste cose strane e
adesso spero di no mi imbatto
sicuramente di no e perché non li
cerchiamo e perché no ed è quindi nato
ma se proprio oggi è online questo sito
in questo momento raccoglitrice circa
150 docenti extraordinaria l'olio net
aria olio italia è un olio extravergine
d'oliva qui l'hanno vista la novità sta
nella modalità di commercializzazione
dell'olio è un ottimo olio extravergine
d'oliva
ma si sa il sito che il packaging sono
gli anta t a presentarlo più come un
prodotto che da dei benefici alla salute
che l'olio extravergine d'oliva
lo sappiamo tutti che date benefici ma
questo viene venduto per quei benefici e
poi alla fine dice se poi vuoi anche
usarlo in cucina poi anche farlo altro
mio scarnera è un fenomeno ha iniziato a
13 14 anni avuto un'idea un'intuizione
ha creato un sito di vendita online di
servizi internet è un po più complicato
vede spazio web pari soltanto con queste
intuizioni di venderlo i suoi coetanei
gente che non poteva spendere più di 10
15 20 euro al massimo questa è una
storia simbolo perché oggi non mi
vergogno a dirlo anzi a dir la verità mi
vergogno un po a dirlo lui guadagna più
di me ha appena compiuto diciott'anni
lui guadagna smart city l'ultimo nato
quattro mesi fa
quattro ragazzi due studenti oggi del
quinto anno due neo diplomati si sono
messi insieme e realizzano siti internet
quindi non è sbagliato scritto supermoto
so che smart city viene scritto in
un'altra maniera ma questo invece è
stato fatto per scelta
la caratteristica loro qual è la loro
caratteristica è che hanno deciso e
stanno facendo quello di confezionare
city that per il cliente e lo
confezionano addosso come se fosse un
lavoro sartoriale infatti lo so
grazie del ceto e la bottega artigiana
del web ci tengo a sottolineare che
tutte queste start up tutte queste
iniziative sono tutte realizzate con un
impegno iniziale o finanziamento
iniziale bassissimo non c'è nessuno che
ha richiesto un impegno importante per
due motivi il primo è perché non ce lo
possiamo permettere lo usiamo la scuola
il secondo è perché mi piace che i
ragazzi si sforzino a trovare delle idee
che siano che facciano più leva su
quello che sanno fare sulle loro
capacità piuttosto che sul denaro e qui
passiamo a quello che è la seconda
condivisione in questo caso invece i
protagonisti sono i nostri studenti gli
start upper se loro hanno iniziato a
condividere le loro storie con loro
colleghi più giovani della scuola media
da oltre un anno i fatti loro vanno
nelle scuole
entra nelle aule dei ragazzi di seconda
e terza media e raccontano loro le loro
avventure spiegano cosa hanno creato e
come le hanno creato e che si tratti di
una carta per avere di sconti o di un
nuovo servizio su facebook o piuttosto
di appunto una nuova t shirt l'effetto
che riescono a suscitare è sempre lo
stesso un grande entusiasmo una grande
curiosità è veramente un fascino a mille
noi abbiamo dato un nome a questo
iniziative di condivisione e una sigla
sembra una formula chimica n 2 y 4b
never too young for business ma è troppo
giovani per il business ragazzi di 15 18
anni che insegnano condividono con
ragazzi più giovani di 13 14 anni le
loro esperienze imprenditoriali e la
cosa funziona
adesso passiamo alla terza condivisione
avevo annunciato all'inizio è una
condivisione appena concepita sono stati
due i fattori che mi hanno spinto a
pensarla il primo fattore è stato il
risultato di un concorso internazionale
il secondo fattore ancora una volta il
bellissimo tema di questo the licks
share
l'anno scorso ho partecipato a un
concorso internazionale e de venuto
fuori da questo concorso che la nostra
esperienza fatte nel salento da oltre 15
anni di avviare studenti delle superiori
quindi ragazzi sotto i 19 anni a creare
impresa a creare start up
ecco questa esperienza risultata essere
unica non solo in italia ma anche in
europa è probabilmente in tutto il mondo
e questa è una cosa straordinaria
no e invece no non è straordinaria dal
mio punto di vista è infinitamente
triste perché io sono convinto che tutti
gli studenti
permettetemi sottolinearlo tutti gli
studenti che pensano di intraprendere un
corso di studi con un indirizzo
economico abbiano il diritto
dal mio punto di vista è dovere va bene
il diritto di sperimentare con le
proprie mani
che cosa significa creare e gestire
un'impresa che cosa significa trattare
con clienti e fornitori con ricavi costi
con le banche e non farlo sotto forma di
simulazione ma farlo nella pura realtà
e allora questo palco oltre a essere
testimone di queste bellissime
straordinarie storie che stiamo
ascoltando insieme e anche testimone di
una storia nuova di una storia che deve
essere ancora scritta ancora vissuta
perché abbiamo deciso di condividere da
domani
e quando intendo domani intendono
domenica ma lunedì da domani lo dice di
condividere le nostre esperienze
gli esercizi gli esempi di start up con
il
del paese con tutte le altre scuole in
italia con tutti gli altri docenti
pubblicheremo su un sito internet
tutti questi esempi metteremo a
disposizione la nostra esperienza per
cercare di fare in modo che questa
esperienza sia emulata e copiata anche
questo progetto ha un nome
gli abbiamo dato un nome suite club
corno voto un acronimo incubatori di
start up degli istituti tecnici
economici
allora adesso permettermi di concludere
con una sorta di esortazione un appello
ecco voglio rivolgere un appello a tutti
i miei colleghi docenti a tutto il corpo
800 italiano qualsiasi ordine e grado
qualsiasi disciplina è una sorta di
invito è un invito a quattro azioni
nuovi invito i miei colleghi a innovare
a sperimentare a creare ma soprattutto a
condividere
grazie